thank you so much for joining and thank
you so much for your patience while i
got all this together fat fingering
things and not knowing how things work
i appreciate you attending let's go
ahead and get started
so
thank you all so much for joining my
presentation entitled keeping your open
source projects accessible to all
this is a topic that is very near and
dear to my heart as you know being who i
am involved in open source
i would not be here if it were not for
the allies
and for the
support and mentorship that i received
in the open source community so
this is my very small way of giving back
and i am so thankful and so grateful
that each and every one of you took time
out of your day to come to this
presentation and i'm also especially
grateful to alex miller and all for the
invite
so thank you all so much and now that
we've got that obligatory sap out of the
way of which i meant every single word
let's go and get started
howdy strangers i'm sorry i love a good
pun
[Music]
so i had to go and throw that in there
planning is is kind of what i get paid
to do so i have to wedge them in
whenever i can
um
you're probably wondering who i am how i
managed to get a dog in here so
my name is treva williams and i am
community manager slash dev advocate i
always want to say avocado for
replicated
pretty much what my job is to do is to
create engagement with open source
projects and also come up with funny
names for things if you're going to
kubecon either virtually or in person
you'll see those random silly things all
around and more likely than that it was
probably me that named it like cubestix
so um before i started to replicate it i
happened to get hired at this company
called rackspace where i was introduced
to this thing called openstack and that
got me involved with open source and the
rest is history
that's how i ended up here
the more interesting
my co-presenter here is sir harold b
gogginson iii otherwise known as goggy
and he is currently chief cuddle officer
for pink penguins
he's an eighth year old jutsu and also
my emotional support animal and he also
works as kind of an unofficial
unofficial support animal at all the
conferences that we go to so
if you feel overwhelmed or you need to
take a break or just need like a hug or
something like that from someone that's
not a person and you see us around feel
free to stop us gagi loves comforting
people so we're available if you need
support
now before i get into the meat and
potatoes i have to do an obligatory plug
for the ones what from me
my company is called replicated
and it is a company that is founded by
and currently run by some amazing people
who go out of their way to create
truly diverse and accommodating
environments for all of us
which is why i'm able to travel with my
support dog and i mean being mostly
fully remote doesn't hurt either but
they really do an excellent job of
making sure that everyone feels
represented and that everyone feels seen
and i'm very grateful and appreciative
of the opportunity to work for such an
amazing company
[Music]
all right so let's talk about what we're
actually here to do or actually i have
one more slide i have to talk about
what it is that i do at replicate
replicated i manage not one not two but
seven open source projects that i
couldn't even fit all the logos for on
this page or actually i might manage
eight i've kind of lost count by now
but basically they pay me to geek out
about things like troubleshoot ttl
outdated all that kind of stuff like
that by the way if you have a few
minutes check out outdated.sh that
website is to die for meaning layout of
course because that's how i think about
things
all right
so um
we're here because we want more
diversity in our open source projects we
want more participation from people of
color we want more participation from
women we want more participation from
non-binary people and from differently
abled people
now i've got a few suggestions on how
that can happen before i do that before
i jump into that i've got to throw some
numbers at you just to make this look
more professional not like i'm just
standing up here showing off my outfit
so according to the bureau of labor
statistics about 22 percent of
professional for programmers are female
34
identify as black asian or latino and
about 16 percent self-identify as
members of ethnic minorities or ethnic
groups
[Music]
so
those numbers aren't great
but i mean when you compare it to u.s
demographics in general it seems like
right about right around what you would
expect
and you would also expect that
contributor of diversity would match
that well unfortunately it does not
so back in 2017 github did a survey
called the open source survey
where they surveyed a total of 5 500
randomly selected people
on
some random questions and they also
included questions about demographic
information
out of all the respondents all fifty
five hundred
ninety five percent identified as male
only three percent identified as female
and one percent identified as non-binary
which is interesting because most open
source contributions happen on the job
so
what is making it to where male
programmers and developers are willing
to contrib willing to contribute to open
source more than their female
non-white counterparts
seriously what the heck is going on
now i don't think this is part of some
grand conspiracy to exclude people that
are non-white cis-head males
but clearly something is
something
discouraging those people from
participating
in
the
i'm sorry i lost my train of thought
something is discouraging non-white
cis-head males from from participating
in open source
fortunately that github survey included
a section where people could respond and
give some of the reasons why they felt
like they didn't want to be participants
in open source
so the most responded was incomplete or
confusing documentation
next was unresponsiveness or dismissive
responses to attempted contribution
third was conflict
fourth unexplained rejection
and fifth
unwelcoming language or content
sorry i skipped a head too fast
now while you can't do a whole lot to
prevent any type of personality conflict
because i mean if someone just happens
to start a conversation about whether or
not people prefer dc over marvel and the
ones who prefer dc start an argument
because of course they're wrong so they
have to defend their point you can't
really do a whole lot about that but
what you do have full control over is
whether or not you respond to those prs
promptly
whether or not you respond politely
and also
whether or not you update your dadgum
docs seriously update your documentation
there is no greater and more annoying
deterrent to getting involved with an
open source project than trying to read
through the documentation and it looks
like someone cut out a bunch of words
having to do vaguely with the project
put them in a jar shook that jar around
dumped it out on the floor and wrote out
whatever the resulting jumble was
update your documentation and when you
can keep it simple one of my favorite
quotes by albert einstein is and i'm
going to paraphrase because i'm reading
this because i'm doing this by memory
if you can't explain it to a
six-year-old then you don't fully
understand it yourself
now that's pretty harsh
but
there's time and a place for the the sat
words
and also you have to remember that not
only is there a large population in our
in our field that aren't
that don't have computer science and
engineering degrees but there are also a
lot of us who speak english as a second
language
and also
folks are getting started younger and
younger these days so they may not have
even had the opportunity to decide not
to take on all that debt to go to school
for computer science or engineering so
keep those people in mind
seriously i can't drive this point
enough
update your documentation
and while you're at it don't assume that
you're don't assume the knowledge level
of your audience
a lot of times we skip over documenting
a specific step or a re or a series of
steps because we do them so frequently
that it's just kind of second nature
to avoid that a good suggestion that i
heard yesterday as a matter of fact is
to have someone totally unfamiliar with
your project look over your
documentation because they're going to
ask the questions that the noobs might
ask
and as i said previously keep it simple
when you can
there is no reason for a quick start to
read like quantum physics
another thing that i am personally a fan
of
fan of is glossaries
if you can include a glossary along with
your project documentation
openstack got a wedge in a mention for
them again
they have a robust very active dedicated
and
incredible community
very diverse community
mostly because they have outstanding
documentation they're
they've managed to grow
from five small
projects to dozens of community
contributed projects that are the basis
for a whole lot of cloud platforms that
you use today
because they have excellent
documentation
and by the way if you've got some time
jump on over to openstack.org and you'll
see what i'm talking about not every
project has great docs cough cloth
triplo but some of them are phenomenal
another reason why you want to include a
glossary is because there are some terms
and phrases
related to your project that are kind of
hard to google
like google will lead you completely in
the wrong direction especially when
you're a baby admin trying to figure out
how something works so it's better to
not leave it up a chance and go ahead
and define it yourself
and speaking of those baby admins
it's very important to have mentorship
programs instead of re rejecting those
bad prs
link up with that person instead
if time permits of course
while it takes extra time it's always
better
to foster a newly but dedicated admin in
in completing their contribution then
they just throw it to the side and
discourage them that's how we lose
contributors across the board not just
people of color not just other other
underrepresented groups
and speaking of underrepresented groups
don't forget about the differently abled
i'm not sure if my gift is playing but
this is a demonstration of a plug-in on
a website by a company called userway i
believe
and in addition to providing
accessibility options that adjust
contrast whether or not gifts or videos
play
text size etc
there's also a dyslexia-friendly font
that i was absolutely amazed to look at
because i hadn't been realized i hadn't
even realized how hard i was training to
follow along with words on a screen
until i didn't have to strain so much to
look at them
so just a small thing like adding a
wordpress plugin to your website into
your documentation can make a huge
difference if it's nothing more than
making the differently abled community
feel seen
so i'm talking a lot in generalities but
we're here because we want more
diversity
the overall message is build it they'll
come
what we all want is more engagement and
more interaction in general
right
right
so if you have excellent documentation
if you have great accessibility options
if you have a really friendly really
robust mentor program if you respond to
those pr's or at least have an outline
setting proper
expectations for when the pr can be
responded to
contributors will come and they'll come
from all communities all backgrounds
but when they get there don't be weird
like please don't be weird about it um
and to give an example of what i mean
like don't prop up the one woman or that
you whose name you know on international
women's day and then forget about women
the rest of the year
instead
celebrate people who are non-white
cis-head meals simply because they did
something great
it makes a difference it's really
obvious when you try to tokenize and
also it's really honorable when you
don't
we're not asking for special treatment
we're just asking to be included
not to mention
having seeing representation for a
person who feels like they can't do the
thing because of where they come from
what their background is or what their
education level is seeing themselves
represented
is encouragement to get involved in
themselves it was certainly an
encouragement for me because
i'm actually a high school dropout i
dropped out in ninth grade now granted i
put myself through college but but
seeing other people who came from
similar struggles is what encouraged me
to at least try
so representation matters just don't be
weird about it
also hammering this again be responsive
when you can and if you can't respond
because i totally understand what it's
like to have to work a full-time job and
try to manage one or several projects by
yourself there's just not enough hours
in the day
if you're not able to clone if you're
not capable of cloning yourself which i
mean shame on you if you can't like the
technology totally doesn't exist but you
should be able to do it anyway
like i mentioned earlier
write an outline to set proper
expectations for when a response can be
expected
which i guess goes back to my previous
point that i keep on bringing up update
your documentation
and while you're at it update that
readme
nothing is more irksome to me personally
than going to a github repo and seeing a
re read me that has nothing but lorem
ipsum or even worse
it has instructions for how to deploy
that are five years old in conflict with
what's on the primary docs on the
website just enough to where when you
try to launch it one way it completely
breaks when you try to do it the updated
way it's still broken so you end up in
this cycle of frustration and you can't
find anything and you end up just kind
of throwing the project to the side
because screw this
update your reading please
when you make push major updates
include at least a note in the readme
about them
update your readme
[Music]
this is the point that i already
mentioned don't reject without reason
now this isn't something that i've seen
happen in the wild i don't think ever
maybe once or twice but i just wanted to
glue this point anyway because it gives
me an excuse to use one of my favorite
gifts
and also to talk about one of my
colleagues who did something incredible
so his name is john murphy you have to
say the whole thing
every time
we had a huge pull request to come in
for one of our open source projects i'm
talking pages long that was
super ambitious very creative
really needed added a lot of features
potentially but there were a few things
that were wrong
well my colleague john murphy spent an
entire month meticulously combing
through his pull request and instead of
rejecting it because we had many
conversations about it
he left notes on every single thing that
needed to be changed every single thing
that needed to be improved every single
thing that we could or couldn't add and
how to fix it and actually ended up
volunteering to mentor this person
and i thought that was very moving
because in him doing that we have gained
a loyal community member and may have
also gained a new engineer because that
person is now interviewing for our
engineering team and replicated so had
to throw in a little kudos for john
murphy
i hope he sees this
thank you so much for being so dedicated
and
well i know i keep saying time doesn't
permit us to do those types of things
all the time when you can do it it makes
a huge difference
so i'm sort of coming up on my clothes
um
our diversity is our power
there have been several studies made
showing
that companies in the tech community
that have diverse
hires
they generally innovate faster
and they generate more money
than more homogeneous cis-head white
male populated
that's a weird way to phrase that then
companies that have mainly cis-head
white male
employees so there's no reason to
believe that the same type of innovation
couldn't happen with more
diverse contribut contributions coming
in
and going back to openstack once again
because they're the ones what from me
they're an excellent
example of what happens when you have a
massive and diverse community
contributing and showing
and
demonstrating
their skill sets
that's a weird way to face that but i'm
going to leave it alone
so yes diversity is important and it
certainly pays off it pays off actually
fairly quickly
so i guess that's all i got i'm sure i
had more written out but i kind of
forgotten now so i'm going to go ahead
and take any questions questions
yes
um is a good example do you have
specific
places within projects within to look at
for good examples of documentation
yes
specific projects to look at would be
openstack heat that is i think cloud
formation on aws
another one will be openstack glance
and
swift has fantastic documentation also
um
there's a quarterly contributor list
that's released um
if we
ping me later i'll give you a bit more
information but those are the three
projects i can think about the top of my
head that have excellent examples of
what i'm talking about
sure
any other questions
yes
one of the problems with documentation
uh
largely is that we're kind of blind to
it because we already know
one of the ways that we try to
get around that is when you're
onboarding
documentation so that you can address
the
black or shared countdown
that is an excellent question that i'm
not sure that i have an adequate answer
for
um
i don't want to stand up here looking
stupid so ping me afterwards and we'll
talk about it
gotta take a second to think about it um
any further questions that i may or may
not be able to answer offhand
all right
okay
all right well thank you so much for
coming um
i just wanted to excuse the wedge and
some blue here because it's my favorite
color
um if you do have any further questions
i do have a little slack channel on the
strange loop 2021 slack and it is that
really long hyphenated thing there at
the bottom
i'll leave this up so that you can take
screenshots and everything but if you
have any questions about this
presentation if you'd like to read or
see what i actually wrote out versus
what i've been rambling about i will
happily send that to you
or if you have any questions in general
that i can help you with or you just
want to know where augie and i are ping
me on there
if you want to see where i got my
numbers from that is on the bureau of
labor statistics website and also
there's a link to userway.org which is
where that plugin that i kind of stand
for comes from
and if you're anywhere out
in the future and you want to know more
about replicated open source or you want
to find me for some other reason
i pretty much live on replicated.com oss
so with that that is pretty much all i
got thank you all so much again i
apologize for the rambling and scrambly
brain but i appreciate you being here
thank you so much and i hope that you
have a great rest of your conference
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
you